[music]
>> Brother somebody we know
from Malaysia.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.
Wa alaykum as-salam warahmatullahi wa
A'uzu billahi min ash-shaytani rajim.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
Allah says in the Quran
Brother and sister
today
I'm going to talk about being a
full-time da'ee.
And I'm going to share to you how I
become a full-time da'ee, brother. In my
place
at the time I was studying, I went to my
a place that I've studying for da'wah.
And then we was having a discussion and
having a critical discussion about
da'wah.
And then rise some question.
This thing can be sought out by by this
department or that department. These
people should do this. That people
should do this. This ustaz should have
done this. This imam should have done
this. But I was sitting there, I was
thinking, what we have done?
And what I have done in order for us to
settle up all the issue that we are
having, especially when it is related
with muallaf
or the people who have reverted. So came
into my mind, someone have to sacrifice
for the goodness of the religion of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And we have a group of people
what we have done
we have come into a common
common acknowledgement and then we have
decided to do a group to do da'wah to
the people who are not yet Muslim and
also to the people who are revert so
that these people can do da'wah to the
to the people who are not yet Muslim.
We believe that people who have reverted
they are some quality that have been
built in together with them whereby the
people who have born Muslim could never
ever have it.
And it is possible for them to have it.
One of it is we have a experience being
a non-Muslim.
Whereby I cannot tell anyone who born as
a Muslim go and gain a experience being
a non-Muslim. So using that we try to
create inshallah a bit of da'ee
to serve
and also to do da'wah
to the non-Muslim.
Brother and sister
at the same time
we have a group of people in my state
some of us
even have leave their job
in order for us to do all these thing.
The message that I wanted to tell tell
to you is
see, at the time we wanted to become a
full-time da'ee, we don't know how we
going to survive.
We don't know what going to happen.
We don't know how would be our future in
terms of this world. But we believe what
Allah mentioned in Surah Muhammad, Surah
47, verse number seven, whoever help
Allah's religion for sure and sure Allah
will help them. Inshallah. Wa akhiru
da'wana as-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wa barakatuh.
Brother Muhammad Fadli from Singapore.
A'uzu billahi min ash-shaytani rajim.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
Rabbi ishrahli sadri wa yassirli amri.
Wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu qawli.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. Wa alaykum as-salam
warahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
I'd like to talk to you about topic
as us
being the product of da'wah.
Having our my own ancestral
who are
coming from Buddhism and Hinduism
and how
by them getting da'wah has led them to
become Muslims.
I believe in fact most of us here
we are all product of da'wah.
We wouldn't be Muslims
if not for all those that have put in a
lot of effort into this.
Like Allah said in the Quran, Surah
Nahl, chapter 16, ayah 125
invite to the way of your lords with
beautiful preaching.
If one not those people who have
followed on to this ayah
or this belief
in fact most of us as most of us here
will not be Muslims.
I'm sorry to say that.
And alhamdulillah
thumma alhamdulillah.
By the blessings and grace of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
we are all Muslims. And now the
importance of da'wah and we wanted to
become a full-time da'ee, in fact as an
effective da'ee
it is our duty now
to spread the word and convey the true
message about Islam
and call people to the deen, inshallah.
Wa akhiru da'wah.
Alhamdulillah rabbil alamin.
Brother Arsh Zagade from India.
Alhamdulillah wa salatu wa salam ala
rasulillah wa ala alihi wa sahbihi
ajma'in amma ba'd. Fa a'uzu billahi min
ash-shaytani rajim. Bismillah Rahman
Rahim.
Wal asr. Innal insana lafi khusr.
Illal lazina amanu wa amilus salihaat.
Wa tawasu bil haqqi wa tawasu bis sabr.
Respected elders and my dear brothers in
Islam, I welcome all of you with Islamic
greetings, as-salamu alaykum
warahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Wa alaykum
as-salam warahmatullahi wa May peace,
mercy and the blessings of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala of almighty God be
on all of you.
The topic of this short talk
is the concept of worship in Islam.
The word worship in Arabic means ibadah,
which means to submit all your services
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala alone.
Mainly when we talk about ibadah, the
first thing comes to our mind
is salah, zakah, hajj, sawm.
Alhamdulillah, these are the
fundamentals of ibadah.
But we do we forget that even the
smallest act we do in our daily life can
be ibadah.
For example, seeking knowledge.
Alhamdulillah, we have gathered here all
to seek knowledge to seek the knowledge
of the techniques of how to do da'wah.
Inshallah, this will be counted in
ibadah.
Meeting with your brothers for the sake
of Allah is also counted as ibadah. Even
a small smile at your face for your
brother is charity. As the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wa sallam said
a smile is a charity.
When a husband feeds
his wife
it's also charity.
So even the small acts we do can be
converted into ibadah and inshallah
which will help us to come to attain
jannatul firdaus, inshallah.
Now, there are some criterias
for the acceptance of ibadah.
The first and foremost is the
intentions, the niyyah.
What's your intention?
For example we have all gathered here
and our niyyah, alhamdulillah, should be
and inshallah it will be
to spread the Islam and to gain the
pleasure of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
If our niyyah switches, if our niyyah is
just so that I can come on the
television of 4K and 8K so that I can be
famous
I'm sorry to tell you this ibadah is not
accepted, in fact you'll get a sin.
So your niyyah should be pure.
The second
is the ibadah which you do, for example,
seeking knowledge or praying, it should
be accordance to the sunnah of Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wa sallam. For example
>> It should be accordance to the Sunnah of
Prophet Muhammad Ali Wasallam. For
example,
how many rak'ahs do you pray in your
Zuhr prayer?
Obviously, four.
But if I say, "No, I'll pray five.
One rak'ah extra because it's greater.
I'll come closer to Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala." No, it's not that case. In
fact, you're doing a bid'ah in Islam.
So, the ibadah which you do should be in
accordance with the Sunnah of Prophet
Muhammad Ali Wasallam.
These are some of the criterias which we
have to follow so that our ibadah will
be acceptable in the sight of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala. May Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala accept our efforts and our
ibadahs and attain and give us Jannah.
Wa akhiru da'wana alhamdulillah rabbil
alamin. Wa assalamu alaykum wa
Wa alaykum assalam wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.
Brother Azran Chan from Malaysia.
Innal hamdulillah, nahmaduhu wa
nasta'inuhu wa nastaghfiruhu. Wa na'udhu
billahi min shururi anfusina wa min
sayyi'ati a'malina. Wa may yahdihillahu
fala mudhilla
wa may yudhlil fala hadiya lahu. Ashhadu
an la ilaha illallah wahdahu la sharika
lahu. Wa ashhadu anna Muhammadan abduhu
wa rasuluh.
Brother and sister,
I come from a Chinese Buddhist family.
And
at the age of at the age of 16,
I
embrace Islam.
Now,
what make me
make this decision?
Okay?
When I look back to the
uh
book of Buddhism, which is the
Tripitaka,
okay?
It was mentioned, you know,
in the
Gospel of Buddha, page 217,
state which says, "Gautama Buddha has
said to his disciple, Nanda, okay? Oh,
Nanda,
I'm neither the first Buddha nor the
last Buddha
who is sent to this world.
Okay?
There will come
the अंतिम Buddha
which
he will possess knowledge and wisdom.
And all shall follow him."
Ladies and gentlemen,
well, uh
at the age of 16, I have left home
and uh
before that, I was in a Christian school
and um
there was a time when the prefect has
organized a spot check in the classroom.
Okay? And there was one classmate of
mine who brought
a
forbidden book to the school.
So, when the prefect's going to check,
he got nowhere to put it. He put it into
my bag.
So, when the prefect check,
I was caught.
So, what happened is another friend went
to
told the
uh religious teacher, you know?
When the religious teacher came
and he has uh
stood up for me.
And then ever since then, I followed the
uh Islamic class in the
uh
So, as uh
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala has mentioned in
the Quran,
qul in kuntum tuhibbunallah
fattabi'uni yuhbibkumullah wa
yaghfirlakum dhunubakum wallahul
ghafurur rahim.
Say that if you love Allah, follow me.
You know? For Allah will love you
and will for- forgive
uh all your sins, you know?
For Allah is the all-forgiving
and uh
all-loving.
With this, I end. Assalamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Thank you
very much. Wa alaykum assalam wa wa
barakatuh.
La
ilaha illallah.
ilaha illallah. [music]
La
ilaha
Muhammadun
>> [music]
>> rasulullah.
Muhammadun rasulullah.
Arju ridhaka [music] ya Allah. Antar
rahimu ya Allah. Hab ni ataka ya Allah.
Antal karimu Allah. Minkal atao ya
Allah. Antal adhimu ya Allah. Fikal
[music] rajao ya Allah. Antal halimu
Ar-rahmanu as-sattaru
malikul mulkil ghaffarul wahhabul
mannanul muta'al.
Ar-rahmanu as-sattaru malikul mulkil
ghaffarul wahhabul mannanul muta'al.
Allahu Allahu ya rabbi ya Allah.
Allahu ya rabbi ya Allah.